all right Johnny
how you doing Johnny where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
I grew up in the San Diego Valley on the
border of East L.A Monterey Park
Alhambra area which is a predominantly
Asian Community even the street signs
are in Chinese there exactly so I had
both my parents my father was
I would say my childhood was kind of
like miserable filled with distrust my
my father was a
uh drunk alcoholic
um
my mom was Taoist Buddhist so you know
it was kind of ran like a dictatorship
and uh
you know we were really young and and
and my dad would actually beat us me and
my brother and my mom I sent my mom to
that I see you a lot of times a bunch of
times
uh so it was very very chaotic as a kid
um
and I think uh you know grew up around
that type of environment where there was
gangs drugs violence
um you know we're low income not
stereotypical Asian but we didn't really
have much money grope around a lot of
Hispanics there was a lot of culture
shock as well
our parents are immigrants so they
didn't really
you know know how to fit in so we kind
of had to learn everything from the
streets
you know when I was young I had a very
peculiar mindset I I trusted in myself a
lot because I felt like I couldn't trust
my parents uh one time you know I was 10
years old and I got jumped for the first
time had my backpack stolen had my my
shoes taken I went home and and my
father asked me where is your backpack
where's your stuff and I said you know I
got jumped by four Hispanics you know
and he didn't believe me he thought that
I threw away my backpack he thought that
I wasn't trying to do good in school so
he beat me after that so yeah I kind of
went through a lot with with the
beatings and a lot of trauma and so at
the age of 12 years old I actually
joined the gang
um I joined the the watchings the
Chinese Triad type of gang out in that
area very big big gang so these are
Asian gangs yes a lot of Asian gangs out
there we're very Incognito Hush Hush
tight lip but they do exist and um
so I joined that at 12 years old
and a lot of people ask me you know why
would you join that you know why would
you join a gang you know at the age of
12 and a lot of people would say it's
probably due to you know their broken
home or a broken family or drugs or
violence just the environment for me
particularly in my opinion I noticed
that uh it stemmed from trusting and
believing myself
when I was young I thought that
if I did everything I wanted to do I
would be happy so having fun going out
with gang members stuff like that I
thought was really fun and the things
that I didn't want to do
such as you know
exercising studying doing homework I
didn't do because I thought if I did
everything I wanted to do I would be
happy and the things that I didn't want
to do I didn't do because I didn't think
it would make me happy so I looked at
the gang life and it started at the core
of my heart you know I really wanted to
be
um a gang member I really wanted to I
looked up to those people and so I
joined that that type of Lifestyle uh 12
months I'm sorry three months into it at
the age of 12.
I caught my first case
um and that was originally a kidnapping
slash robbery but they dropped the
charges down uh they're 12 years old at
12. yeah and ended up
um it was with a group of people of
course but ended up uh catching the
charge for dissuading a witness for the
benefit of a gang so uh ended up going
to Y.A
um California Youth Authority I was at
srcc first and then
um caught a couple fights in there got
written up they called it level bees and
then ended up going to Fred see now this
Nellis y a and
you know I was 12 years old they gave me
four years
um and when I was in ya I learned a lot
of like it cultivated the mindset to
believe in myself even more I really
trusted myself because I had seen rapes
I had seen murders I had seen stabbings
fightings I've I learned how to fight
there they called it Gladiator school
for a reason you know you fight a lot
and I learned like the two second
takeoff rule meaning if you feel
disrespected within two seconds you have
to handle it whether it's stabbing them
fighting them beating them up otherwise
you'll be labeled a punk
excuse my language a [__] a Leva stuff
like that so
um you know I did four years there and
it was really really traumatic and um I
get out
you know 67 days two months in a week I
catch my second case this time I'm an
adult they try me as an adult uh it's
two counts of a soul with deadly weapon
um again it was It was supposed to be a
robbery and attempted but
they dropped the charge down I pled out
um they gave me 10 years 85 percent so
Aid and some change
um so yeah I get to prison and it's a
whole nother ball game it's uh first off
I'm Chinese so so being there we were
outnumbered um it really was a racial
thing whereas in y a it was more of
gangbang it was a little bit of race but
you had to represent your your colors
represent your flag represent your your
people but when you go to prison you
have to drop your flag you have to drop
everything and you have to represent the
other car or the the the race right so
in there I had to calm down because I
was a ya baby
um I didn't know how to program
after about a year I learned how to
program the rules of regulations and
everything and I was able to
really start to kind of function in
prison
um you know I went through a lot of
depression
so I had uh seen some counselors in
there you know I'm just being honest
like I was able to get my GED I was able
to get anger management counseling and
everything looked on the up but there
was one thing that I really couldn't get
rid of and it was this emptiness and
this void I had felt inside of my heart
no matter what I did I really couldn't
overcome this emptiness in this void
and uh it didn't matter what I did you
know I just always felt this sadness and
feeling inadequate as a human being and
so you know some of the the older homies
the people in there the the people who
kind of like represent us they we you
usually look to them for advice so uh
one of the older guys some old Chinese
dude he's like bro you should start
reading you know and working out and and
kind of get your mind off of things
because he noticed that I was kind of
like an overthinker and um so I started
reading I read the Quran in there front
to back three times read the Bible in
there front to back two times
um and you know it didn't really do
anything for me honestly so
um I get out after doing my stretch I
parole out of CRC Norco and um
I meet my mom you know and she didn't
really visit me much she's an older lady
she didn't know how to navigate the
correctional facilities and stuff like
that so she didn't really visit me but I
noticed a difference in my mom you know
she had this uh
this inner peace about her that I really
didn't understand because
mind you she's she has not just me but
my brother two kids in prison
um who are incarcerated my did my
brother did also 12 years and um she had
she was still married to my father her
husband who was still an abusive
alcoholic person she still lived in
section 8. she still had you know all
that trauma and and stuff like that but
she had no circumstances to be happy but
I I realized that she was happier than I
was you know and so I asked my mom my
mom why are you so happy you know what
what changed and then she mentioned
church and at that time honestly it's
like I rolled up the car the windows in
the car you know I was like I'm not
trying to hear about that Mom I'm I'm
I'm not I don't believe in God we're a
raised Buddhist I'm good so she said
fair enough you know she didn't push she
didn't say anything
she just let me be so as I got out I had
that heart that I wanted to still do
better and do good you know I had lived
my my whole life doing bad things and
following myself trusting myself so I
wanted to get a job I wanted to help my
parents help you know and um I tried to
look for a job but as a two-strike felon
with a violent crime
yeah it wasn't happening I I applied for
even like McDonald's FedEx UPS all the
places that they say they hire convicted
felons and I wasn't showing any love
honestly but
um immediately I went back to the
streets you know I started to sell drugs
again and at that time
you know I was still on parole so it's
very risky looking over my shoulder and
I just felt like this was not something
I could make a career out of
and so
um you know I devised this plant to
actually rob a drug dealer you know
because my thinking at the time was if
I'm selling all these drugs it's risky
but if I just Rob someone who sells all
the drugs then I would inherit and gain
a lot of money so I had I had it was me
and a friend of mine he was like my road
dog
and I told him hey bro let's let's Rob
this dude he's a well-known drug dealer
in our area anyway
um you know I told him I was gonna go to
the red car he was going to go to the
left of the car and
um you know when I stepped to go to the
right of the car he actually my friend
stepped in front of me so naturally I
went to the left of the car as I'm
walking up on the driver's side of the
car I hear three gunshots you know and
when it rang out I actually assumed
initially that it was my friend who who
shot the dude you know I was like damn
you didn't even give him a chance well
whatever you know it is what it is we'll
roll with the punches we're very cold
like that but
actually the car sped off and I realized
it was my friend that had gotten shot
and um
you know he was just laying there I
remember vividly like the sounds the
noise that he was making and and he was
dying and there I'm holding him and he
died in my arms you know and
yes every time I think about that I get
a little emotional but
um
you know I that moment was very pivotal
in my life because
I had thought about it like that was
supposed to be me actually if I went to
the right of the car I would have been I
probably wouldn't be here today
so you know as I seen that
I started to really think in my life
like I could feel Death Around the
Corner you know it didn't matter what I
would do I I felt like my time I was on
borrowed time I felt like I was gonna
die soon and three days after that I had
received a letter from one of my my
friends just a childhood friend he grew
up with us in the projects and section
eight he
um
he gave me a letter that that was really
eerie you know he's like you know think
about me when I'm gone and just saying
these types of things and and three days
after that I find out that he had
committed suicide in jail
so there was death all around me and I
was feeling that you know it was
creeping up on me
and um you know miraculously my mom
actually a couple days after these
incidents had happened her car had
broken down and she was like hey Johnny
like
um I need you to take me to church you
know she's a translator she was very
like involved at the time and so I said
yeah there's no harm in that you know I
want to help Mom out you know I didn't
spend all my life you know being bad to
her so I wanted to treat her well so I
took her to the church but I told her
very specifically I don't want to be
evangelized I don't want to I don't want
to talk to the pastor
um and so
when I get there I remember this pastor
Runs Out
and he's like hey Johnny you know good
to see you and and why don't you come on
in for some food you know and they had
made like some some black bean noodles
and that's actually my favorite dish you
know I love eating black bean noodles
for those Asian Sundown people out there
who know what I'm talking about it's
like a delicacy for us you know I grew
up eating that stuff so
um I was like what's the harm in eating
you know but I told the pastor I don't
want to hear about God I don't believe
in God and I'm Buddhist Etc et cetera so
we get there and
um
I remember he sits down and after we
finish eating he he asks me two
questions that really kind of shocked me
you know he said are you a sinner and do
you know what sin is and at that time I
felt a little angry to be honest because
I felt like that was a loaded question
like who is who's not a sinner you know
we're all born imperfect we're all
flawed as human beings we've all made
you know bad decisions in our life and
stuff like that so I kind of got mad and
I told him yeah of course and and he
said so what do you think about Sin you
know I said well sin is when you do
something bad and then you know you go
against God or you you know shoot people
stab people you know lie to people
that's a sin
and he said not so
and that was the first time that it kind
of like he shook my world upside down I
was like what do you mean you know this
is kind of weird because that's what I
always learned even though I wasn't
Christian uh Catholic or anything like
that I knew that doing bad things is not
it's a No-No you know you don't do that
but he explained to me that sin was
actually twofold the first thing is it's
trusting yourself above the word of God
so trusting yourself more than God
that's what sin is and number two it was
inheritance so he explained to me the
analogy of you're Chinese you didn't
choose to be Chinese you were born that
way your father was Chinese his father
was Chinese Etc it was passed down
likewise with sin it wasn't that you did
anything wrong but
your fault you know Adam was uh was evil
he was sinful and then it passed down to
us so we were born as Sinners and at
that time it really made sense to me
because my son you know he was like four
years old at the time and you know I
always taught him well you know hey
don't don't follow the way that Daddy
went you know like be good respect your
elders et cetera et cetera never taught
him how to lie steal or do anything like
that
um but at the age of four you know he
loved eating gummy bears and I remember
like he would always want gummy bears if
he could just live off of gummy bears he
would do it but with the veggies you
know I told him you have to eat veggies
first and then you can eat some gummy
bears but I would see him trying to hide
the veggies trying to take it to the
little potty and throwing it in there
and you know who taught him that you
know and and he even got to a point
where he would he would steal the gummy
bears he would scoot the little stool
over climb on top reach at the top of
the cabinet pull out the uh the gummy
bears and and I caught him red-handed
I'm what are you doing one day and he
was like nothing there nothing you know
so who taught him that I never taught
him any of that evil stuff but it was
part of him and it was something that
was actually normal for him for kids to
rebel and then he used the analogy of an
apple tree which really put it in
perspective he said when you look at the
seeds of an apple where are the apples
but if you plant it as it grows it'll
only produce apples no matter how hard
it tries it cannot produce oranges or
mangoes likewise when you look at a baby
where is the sin it's very cute it's
loving but as it grows as it matures all
you see is sin and they start to you
know lie they start to
cheats still they can even murder you
know and so when I saw that it really
made
a lot of sense to me as a person and I
was able to see that oh we're just being
normal it's not that I did bad things
and then I became a sinner no I was born
flawed I was born imperfect and he had
mentioned you're an imperfect person
trying to produce perfect results of
course you're gonna fall short so that's
why I had emptiness and and depression
and loneliness inside of my heart
because he was showing me that it wasn't
the surface level things but it was at
the core of the heart because everything
is rooted in the Heart Right everything
came from from from the the center so I
was trying to basically put a Band-Aid
like oh I had anger so I take anger
management no if you look if you peel
back the layers of an onion you'll
realize that you'll get to the root of
it which was sin produces everything and
I started to realize oh I was looking at
it from a wrong perspective so
he said it's okay you know and then huge
analogy of like a car and and he was
saying that uh there's a braking system
in the car and it must overcome the
accelerator otherwise you know if the if
the accelerator overcomes the brake we
will crash right no one would drive that
car even if it was a Ferrari because it
has no brakes likewise we are people who
need to have self-control if we don't
have self-control and our desires or
like the accelerator if it keeps going I
want to do drugs I want to make money
then you'll if you don't manage that
you'll crash out in life and you'll live
miserably and when he was saying these
things it was hitting me in the core of
my heart like wow this guy knows me but
I just met him you know I really didn't
understand how he knew me through and
through you know and at that time he
said you're a person because you were
born flawed imperfect in sin you don't
have the capability to stop yourself and
so you need something else to help you
and in that case he said that's where I
come in as a pastor he said I am your
braking system right so at that time he
had asked me
uh this one question and he said how is
your relationship with your father
said it's horrible I honestly hate him
you know I
I feel like the reason why I joined a
gang the reason why I was angry the
reason I was so like violent was because
of my father but
she had mentioned okay so listen to me
very carefully he said when you meet
your father I want you to apologize to
him
and I was like what excuse my language
but I was like [__] that honestly
because
I didn't ask to be born
um he had a responsibility to take care
of me but when I was born you know he
beat me and he didn't he wasn't there
for me and I felt like just so angry
when he he asked me to apologize to him
and you know what he said was he said
Johnny you're right
but because you're right you know that
he beat you and you didn't have a good
childhood you're also miserable
and that hit me you know really deeply
you're miserable because when you go
outside and you see fathers who who do
respect their children who did raise
them well
um you know you you feel that pain
he said you know why do people argue why
do people fight why is there no peace
because two people are right you're
right I'm wrong the other party thinks
no I'm right you're wrong right and then
they start to fight and then there's no
peace but when one person becomes wrong
he says then everything drops and then
they can start to heal he starts to come
in you know and they're able to grow
so he said even though you don't
understand it I ask that you accept what
I'm saying and just move forward so at
that time I put down everything I felt
and I trusted this man right and I was
like okay I'm not gonna trust myself
let me see what he says and let me just
try it out you know what's the harm in
trying it out
so I call my father and it's such an
awkward phone call I haven't talked to
him for years and I say hey dad it's
Johnny it's like who I think it's your
son he's like oh
and the first thing out of his mouth I
remember vividly was
I don't have any money for you
and I was like you know I got a little
angry you know I need your money but
kind of simmered down and I was like you
know Dad I just want to talk to you it's
really urgent I need to speak to you
about something said okay
so we plan to go to this fall restaurant
in Alhambra and we get there he's
sitting across from me I'll never forget
it's awkward there's so much tension
he's not looking at me in my face I'm
looking off to the wall and
and every but I remember vividly what
the pastor told me you know just move
forward just apologize it's okay you
know I am your braking system right so I
told him dad
you know I'm here today to tell you that
I'm sorry I'm sorry for being a bad son
I'm sorry for being
not bad
sorry
I'm sorry that I wasn't there for you
that I didn't help
and I and I didn't live up to your
standards
and then my father actually
he started crying
he said no
I'm sorry
I'm sorry to be a bad that I was a bad
father I'm sorry I didn't give you a
good childhood and I'm sorry I couldn't
control my drinking and that you had to
suffer because of that
you know
[Music]
20 years of pain
anger frustration
it was crushed
we hugged it out
and I now we have a great relationship
you know
when I think about it
if I had never followed what the pastor
said if I never trusted him and I
trusted myself if I tried to understand
and wrap my head around it if I held my
own righteousness I would have never
experienced this
at the core of my heart Pastor was
dissecting it and fixing it from the
inside out
and when I seen that I was so thankful
wow this pastor he knows something that
I don't know for the first time in my
life I didn't trust what I saw and what
I felt I left it in the hands of someone
who was better than me who knew God who
lived happier than me who was more
peaceful than me and when I was
connected to that I was able to overcome
everything I see my father every week
now we go out to eat and all we talk
about is happiness and and we're able to
rekindle everything
and I never preached the gospel to my
dad I never told him about God I just
showed him hey you know I'm happy Dad
and I love you and that love really
overcame everything you know so
you know forgiveness yeah forgiveness
and it wasn't like I wanted to but when
I connected to something you know that
was stronger than me like my pastor I
was able to stay out of prison I was
able to kick the drugs I was on meth and
ecstasy and Coke
it wasn't that I did anything myself I
didn't even want the help you know a lot
of people were on skid row and they they
talk about homelessness oh the problem
is wholeness well if you peel that back
it could be mental issues mental health
if you peel that back you could be you
know drugs and whatnot but the truth is
it's at the core of the heart I believe
it's sin and if you don't get rid of
that aspect then there's no that begets
everything else it produces everything
else so I I liken it to like the analogy
of cancer
say I have cancer and if I'm losing my
hair and if I'm losing weight well if I
put a wig on and I just eat and fatten
up it doesn't get rid of the cancer so
likewise we have to get to the core of
the issue and the core of this issue
right now is people's hearts their
self-worth is completely gone there when
you so when the pastor planted hope
inside of my heart it casted everything
out he never said don't do this stop
doing drugs stop game he never told me
that he didn't give me a dime you know
what he gave was hope inside of my heart
and when that happened we naturally
dropped everything else that was
hopeless I clinged on to jugs because I
thought that that was my hope I clinged
onto my gang because that was my hope at
the time but when God showed me another
perspective he talked he talked about
God
you know he talked about Jesus and he
said why did why do you think that Jesus
had to die for you
well because you're a sinner you're born
into sin you can't stop sinning so
you'll always be empty you'll always be
miserable but when you think about God
he paid for all of your sins he made you
righteous and I'm like he made me
righteous like I'm a sinner I remember
my sins and he said well God doesn't
remember them Hebrews 10 17 it says and
their sins and iniquities will I
remember no more so
he said you have a choice to make Johnny
are you going to trust what you think
and what you feel which is constantly
changing it's like the ocean high tide
low tide one minute I love this woman
next minute we argue and fight I hate
her I'm telling her get out of my house
am I gonna trust his heart that
constantly changes one minute I make a
determination I throw all of my pipes
away I'm not going to do drugs next
minute I'm rummaging through the trash
again picking it all up am I gonna trust
something that constantly changes and he
told me if something is constantly
changing if a person says one thing and
does another he's a liar so would you
trust his heart that lies to you or are
you going to trust the word of God that
never changes no matter what God died
for you he perfected you he made you
holy past present and future sins are
gone you know and
when I believed I put again myself down
and my thoughts down and I trusted the
word of God that power became mines and
he likened it to the knowledge of like a
debt let's say Mark you know I have
ten thousand dollars for you and I say
let's go to Arizona you know and in
Phoenix in one week I'll give you ten
thousand dollars if you believe in me if
you trust what I say you will make that
trip and you'll go out there and you'll
receive the ten thousand but let's say
you don't believe in me ah Johnny is a
gang member he's just a guest on
software underbelly I don't believe him
even if I go to Arizona with ten
thousand dollars
you will not receive the blessing right
so it's it's important to where you put
your beliefs in people say Lord is my My
Savior well what did he save you from he
saved you from your sins so if he saved
you from your sins and you still think
you're a sinner that must mean he failed
and he did it he says in the Bible that
he's perfected us forever right so
when I was able to believe that that
core of my heart changed I went from
emptiness to having hope but where do
righteous people go righteous people go
to heaven I always thought I was going
to die and go maybe not to hell but
somewhere where evil people go because I
was an evil person I did a lot of things
that I'm not proud of but you know as I
had that hope that hey I don't have to
live this way this mind this heart was
deceiving me telling me that I was you
know not righteous telling me that I was
evil you know and
um when you live that lifestyle you
start to believe well I'm evil anyway so
excuse my language but [__] it I'm gonna
do whatever I want because your
self-worth is gone your your confidence
gone everything is out the window so
you know what I'm doing nowadays is I'm
going to prison and I'm a prison
Minister and I preach my testimony and
this story to people and it really
changes their lives because everyone is
telling people hey stop doing bad stop
doing evil the problem is they're not
understanding that trusting in
themselves is the root of all evil
because we're flawed as human beings
right and if we're flawed we cannot
produce perfect things we actually can't
produce good things we can try but at
the end of the day we feel this
emptiness and what I call it is this up
and down lifestyle you know when you're
really happy you're on the up but when
you're sad you crash so you're happy sad
happy sad happy sad until you die there
is no real purpose inside of your life
you know and and that's something that
people really resonate with because I
went through that when I look at my life
I thought it was a curse 12 years old in
y a like I'm not supposed to be here I'm
supposed to be dead I'm supposed to be
on the streets here with these people
strung out
um but
as I see that God was leading my life I
see that it's such a blessing Blissful
life why because I understand the people
that that these homeless people on the
streets they don't need money they don't
need you know clothes and and all that
you know they need the fixing and the
renewal of the heart
and so you know that's really what I've
been doing nowadays is going to prisons
and talking to you know inmates and
double lifers people with l-wop life
without parole and I don't tell them hey
you need to change why did you murder
people you know you need to make a
decision no what I tell them is do you
know what God did for you do you know
that sin is not it was part of you it's
not that you wanted to do it but it was
something that was dragging you and if
you learn to distrust that voice
distrust that destructive voice I call
it that evil thought evil nature then
you're able to live well and you're able
to connect to the pastor you know you're
able to connect to people who are better
than you and then their happiness their
hope will pour into your heart and once
that changes they start to you know
become mentored they start to also
Mentor other inmates and we're making a
big impact in all these prisons I go to
Thailand I also preach at the bank one
prison I go to Korea recently I met with
post-consulates and I'm a person that
I'm from the San Diego from watching how
can I be talking about God well I really
feel like it wasn't me you know I feel
like God had prepared this for me and he
had showed me something while going
through the struggles while feeling
empty and overcoming that and that's
really what I want to kind of share with
the people because if that Pastor never
gave me a chance if he never explained
to me you know these things I would
probably be dead or in prison how's your
brother
oh he's he's good he's out of prison he
got out about four years ago he comes to
church with me as well and and yeah he's
he's happy he's really happy it's great
it's a hell of a story of forgiveness
and change of heart yeah
that's forgiveness and understanding
that we are already flawed and it's okay
when we put our power down to trust in
ourselves and believe in ourselves then
you know truly God can work you know
because then we start to lean on him
like I said it didn't make sense to say
sorry to my father it made more sense in
my head for him to apologize to me but
when I put that down truly I became
happy and you know I I never thought
that I could rekindle this I I thought I
wasn't even going to visit my father on
his deathbed like that's how much hatred
I had for him but now that I think about
it I'm so thankful for him you know that
I was able to experience God through
this and my my father now like I said
comes to church he hated church he was
like they brainwashed you they don't
give them your money you know they're
there's only women at church because
they're you know it was it was just all
this stuff but you know when he saw that
I had stopped going to prison I had
stopped doing drugs stopped carrying a
gun started to really peek at interest
in him and so he himself went to my
pastor the same Pastor that preached to
me and now he realized you know wow I'm
I'm perfect you know through God through
Jesus because he didn't fail not because
we do well not because he stopped
drinking not because he stopped beating
my mom and in the end
he really gave up drinking him and my
mom are still married I mean it's it's
amazing truly what what the heart when
the heart changes
It's a Wonderful story and
thank you Mark thank you for sharing it
Johnny
thank you appreciate you